termes annuels le thomann fondateur
d'euro continent tire emmanuel thomann
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors un sommet européen
on le disait qu'ils se concentrent sur
deux dossiers les tensions en
méditerranée orientale avec le conflit
grèce turquie et la biélorussie alors
sur ces dossiers l'union européenne at
elle intérêt à se montrer capable de
fermeté sur la scène internationale
est-ce qu'elle en est capable
alors lignes européennes étaient
effectivement encerclés par deux arts de
crise
l'arc de crise méditerranéen qui inclut
évidemment le la le conflit la rivalité
avec la turquie et la crise à l'est de
l'europe avec la russie et tous les pays
de l'ex urss qui oscille entre l'union
européenne et la russie l'union
européenne elle même n'a pas les clés
pour réellement peser sur aucun de ces
dossiers
car les états membres sont divisés parce
qu'ils ont une perception de sécurité
différentes évidemment les pays à l'est
se préoccupe de la russie et les pays
méditerranéens sont plus préoccupés par
la de crise au sud
la libye est aussi la méditerranée la
crise entre la grèce et chypre et la
turquie
somos alesi je vous en prie oui nous
sommes dans une situation où l'union
européenne est de plus en plus fragmenté
en réalité puisque même avec cet accord
sur le plan de relance qui faisait
espérer un sursaut de l'union européenne
en fait il ya des des rivalités entre
états membres entre le nord le sud l'est
et l'ouest
et évidemment les rivalités
géopolitiques en fonction des théâtres
et des perceptions de sécurité il faut
voir aussi que l'union européenne à
cause de désaccords de leur état membre
n'a pas de stratégie géopolitique c'est
à dire n'est pas capable d'établir des
nairas
shi et donc elle réagir aux crises qui
ont qui se produisent sur son pourtour
géographique
alors que la une stratégie cohérente
devrait pousser l'union européenne a
notamment faire face à un adversaire
géopolitique de plus en plus déstabilisé
déstabilisateur qu'ils à la turquie qui
devient l'élément le plus grave pour
l'union européenne la turquie non
seulement déstabilise la liste ci ont
ciré maintenant dans le monde maintenant
dans le caucase et l'union européenne
perd son temps par exemple a essayé
d'appliquer des sanctions en biélorussie
on appelle n'a pas les clés non plus
pour mes pouces et un changement
l'égyptien les mamelles ottomane sur le
dossier en méditerranée orientale
justement les vingt-sept il se dirige
plus vers des sanctions comme vous venez
d'en parler ou sous la médiation est ce
qu'elle est encore possible où ni l'un
ni l'autre
je pense que les états membres
n'arriveront pas à se mettre d'accord
sur des sanctions est en tout cas s'il y
avait quelques sanctions elles seraient
tellement diluées et faible quelques de
toute façon elles n'auront pas d'impact
sur la situation ce qui est beaucoup
plus effectif c'est sans doute des
coalitions d'état qui essayent de
contrer la turquie par exemple lorsque
la france envoie des navires pour
épauler la grèce ou sheep je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus utile pour pour
contrebalancer la turquie mais l'union
européenne elle même est trop divisée
pour moi un impact donc ces sanctions
n'aura pas beaucoup d'effet mais c'est
pareil mais par exemple comme chypre
quand chypre met son veto à toute mesure
concernant la biélorussie tant que la
turquie n'est pas sanctionné par l'union
européenne
là ça montre bien effectivement qu'il va
être difficile de parler d'un front
commun
bien sûr et donc l'âme il faut voir la
situation c'est-à-dire chypre un état
membre de l'union européenne et de facto
occupé par une puissance tierces la
turquie
et l'union européenne n'arrive même pas
à se mettre d'accord pour contrer la
turquie alors que les discussions pour
sanctionner le régime loukachenko alors
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d'enjeu de
sécurité grave pour l'union européenne
donc les pays comme la grèce ou chypre
est d'ailleurs soutenue par l'autriche
et puis de manière plus - moins forte
mais mais aussi fermée au niveau
bilatéral par la france se préoccupe
beaucoup plus de ce qui se passe en
méditerranée mais à nouveau
l'union européenne réagit aux crises
dans son pourtour
alors qu'une le le vrai acteur qui
pourraient avoir une influence décisive
sur ces dossiers et qui aura d'ailleurs
une influence décisive sur ces dossiers
tant vis-à-vis de la turquie notamment
qui élargit s est d'élargir sa zone
d'influencé en envoyant des djihadistes
dans le caucase après la syrie et la
libye et aussi pour résoudre la
transition ou le la stabilisation en
biélorussie c'est la russie
mais non ce qu'ils trouvaient un intérêt
géopolitique pour l'union européenne se
rapprocher la russie pour faire face aux
crises au sud en méditerranée et
vis-à-vis de la turquie mais évidemment
pour l'instant les états membres sont
trop divisés et donc ce seront des
coalitions de volonté entre états comme
par exemple la france et la russie qui
essayent de modérer le conflit dans le
caucase ou d'essayer de d'épauler la
grèce et chypre pour contrer la turquie
qui seront beaucoup plus utile en fait
merci beaucoup
tiens emmanuel thomann pour votre
analyse votre expertise et votre
éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes fondateur
d'euro continent